there is an extremely disturbing report
in the Washington Post which confirms
actually exactly what we would expect
from Donald Trump which is that Donald
Trump told officials he would pardon
them if they break the law in order to
start building that dumb stupid border
wall that he has completely failed to
make any progress on now you might have
forgotten about this because Donald
Trump lies so much and he promises so
much that he's never going to do that
Donald Trump promised his supporters
that he would have by Election Day of
2020 built at least 500 miles of that
fence or border wall it's not going well
because nothing is happening there's
been about 60 miles of border wall
replaced that was old and needed to be
replaced no new wall has been built so
Donald Trump now in an act of
pre-election desperation I guess we
would call it is directing people to
break the law to make at least some of
the wall happen and he is reportedly
dangling pardons in front of people in
advance for crimes that they would have
to commit in order to make it happen
this includes seizing private land for
the wall this includes environmental
rules it includes fast-tracking billions
of dollars in construction contracts
that have not gone through the actual
approval process and the way that
multiple official officials told it to
the Washington Post Trump calls people
into meetings and he tells them what
they want he says start doing it do what
you need to do and build this dam wall
and people say you know mr. president we
can't just start doing that some of what
you're suggesting is illegal some of it
is politically impossible we just really
can't do it and Trump says start doing
it and if there are crimes I will pardon
people quote don't worry
I'll pardon you he has told officials
about just starting to build the wall
once again the White House was asked for
comment they do not deny it later Trump
calls it fake news which is a denial
that is worth absolutely nothing the
most important thing is the White House
asked to comment and they say oh it was
just a joke they don't deny that it was
said now I know that because we're all
so desensitized to the scofflaw nature
of this presidency I need to be explicit
here
this would be impeachable this is
depending on who you talk to conspiracy
to obstruct justice on a large scale
this is something that the Trump astride
will defend by saying they all do it
look at Obama he ate fancy mustard and
wore a tan suits and on another day it
it's every single day it's another
absolutely insane headline that would
have seemed unbelievable before the
Trump era and now it doesn't even get
the attention that it should because we
have been so desensitized and the
constant endless scandal has been so
normalized that it barely makes a blip
it's getting some attention but it's not
getting nearly the attention that it
deserves now one thing that we're
learning is that front and center this
administration has shown us there is way
too much gray area about what is legal
for a president to do a lot of these
academic legal questions about what are
the limits of executive power can a
sitting president be indicted or not
does anything a president does any
action a president takes become legal by
virtue of the president doing it the
infamous if the president does it it's
not illegal these with some very rare
exceptions like Richard Nixon which
ultimately was not tested because the
guy resigned
these were academic hypotheticals in the
Trump era these are real practical
questions and what is abundantly clear
is there is that there's just too much
gray area here we've not had presidents
before try to flaunt the audacity to
stretch the limits of presidential
authority and responsibility this
blatantly now we do and it's clear that
it needs to be dealt with because he is
flaunting his lawlessness on the world
stage and so far to almost no
consequences whatsoever
this is an impeachable offense it's
impeachable bribery some would call it
again conspiracy to obstruct justice by
preemptively saying commit crimes and
I'll pardon you letting them know ahead
of time this is yet another one of these
crises and it's getting you know
some some news coverage and it's going
to be eclipsed in the next six to twelve
hours for sure by the next thing that
happens with things need to change and
things need to change quickly at all
levels the gray area of presidential
authority needs to be made less gray
Donald Trump needs to be removed in
November of 2020 this is only the
beginning and yet it is not stopping
it's getting worse every single day